c'est parti alors je vous ai dit qu'on
allait à moscou ouais on connaissait
tchernobyl oui la ville où la
catastrophe nucléaire s'est produit vous
avez entendu parler tourisme extrême est
insupportable il vient avec pas nature
nabu la centrale de tchernobyl et toutes
les filles
il fallait évacuer avant la nuit même
ils n'ont eu le temps de rien à ramasser
les usines les écoles les magasins les
appartements tout est encore là si ces
prêts pitch là où habitaient les
familles et des employés de tchernobyl
réacteur numéro 4 ou le catastrophe est
arrivée c'est sécuritaire je compte un
regain d'i racines niveau de radiation
ou non dites moi si vous voyez bouger
quelque chose dans une histoire comme
celle-là
il faut partir de maintenant il va
falloir bientôt câbles ont été détruits
et pourtant ça vous dirait que c'est un
bébé
vous êtes sûr que nous sommes seuls ici
oh mon dieu
c'est un animal non c'était autre chose
wisco va aller pour aller retrouver mis
pour passer par la juge pas sûr non mais
là c'est un peu ça lui
nous je ne suis pas une chasse
si les pièces manquaient pas sur mon
frère
chez nous
[Applaudissements]